[Music]
growing up in the 80s and 90s we had a
lot of various specials that always
acted like they were gonna scare us
Weah Tales from the Crypt are you afraid
of the dark goosebumps all sorts of
various shows that kept explaining how
they were gonna scare the crap out of us
and don't get me wrong I like these
shows I think they're really creative
but there's always one problem to me
they were never scary evil miles a kid
how saying to myself where's the scary
stuff where's the stuff that's gonna
fuel my nightmares where's the stuff
that's gonna keep me up watcher in the
woods is that movie yes it's Disney and
yes it's technically family-friendly
but it works like any great scary horror
film a lot of atmosphere a lot of
buildup a lot of mystery a lot of great
shots and a lot of creepy as well as
clever imagery the story is a family is
looking in Britain for a new house to
move into they of course find a big
creepy place that of course has this
terrible backstory and uncomfortable
landlord and all sorts of supernatural
things happening around it both the
daughters in the family seem to have
strange things happening to them the
youngest is almost being taken over like
a puppet and the older has a tendency to
feel the presence of people that were
once there before just feel all sorts of
uncomfortable things slowly but surely
the truth about the disappearance of a
certain girl named Karen comes to light
and the daughters are trying to figure
out if it's the ghost of Karen that's
trying to get in contact with them or
something else what I like about this
film is that there's very few things
that actually separate it from a kid
scary film and a regular scary film in
fact I think this film has a lot more
atmosphere and scares than most scary
films the only difference is there's no
gore murdering or swear words in it as
well as the pacing is a little quicker
than that of a usual scary movie but
again they want to keep the kids
attention but apart from that they treat
a pretty adult notice how many quiet
moments are in this yeah remember that
you could have family films that had
quiet moments there didn't always need
to be a ton of music or talking this is
called establishing mood and it's Dunc
right here the shots are also great I
absolutely love how they make these
woods both beautiful and creepy at the
same time the cinematography
surprisingly kind of has an evil dead
feel to it obviously not as over-the-top
but just as clever with its
setups my favorite shot is right in the
opening it's just a car pulling into the
place
well that's no biggie well that shot was
kind of sloppily done wait a minute why
are we still rolling oh my god this is a
point of view shot
what's watching them what's going on
okay it's not a big scare but at the
same time it kind of catches you off
your guard it's setting up something you
didn't know what's being set up and
that's what a good scary film should do
the fine thing too is that there's a lot
of point view shots in this film but
just when you're about to get sick of
them they do something new with it for
example here's a shot of her just going
through the woods yeah yeah something's
watching her we've seen that a million
times but then at some point she goes
inside and wait a minute it's still out
there why would they show this shot if
something wasn't gonna happen and it
does and it was properly built up and
properly delivered and just we think a
shot like that can't make you
uncomfortable again there's another
scene where she's being followed well
okay again we've seen that a million
times but wait a minute now what's
inside we didn't know it could go inside
every time we've seen it it's always
been outside every time they do
something with a point of view shot they
add something new to put you in a new
state of uncomfortableness it doesn't
downplay anything because it's also
gonna be shown to kids no it wants to
scare the kids because that's why you're
seeing a scary movie I always hate it
when those other shows had to clean it
up and not make it too creepy this goes
all out there and tries to scare you
without actually psychologically harming
you kids can be drawn in to smart things
and scary films can be smart the only
downside I have of this film is that the
acting from the main character is not
very good it's really hokey and awkward
and kind of reminds me of the girlfriend
from airplane but I did see something in
the mist at the pond that's why I fell
in but even then I don't mind too much
because the whole film has such a
strange feel to it that even the acting
in its weirdness actually kind of blends
in the whole film style is so uniquely
its own that you kind of get used to it
and maybe a guy adds to the weird
feeling that you have throughout the
entire movie I don't want give away too
much as part of the fun is being scared
and surprised by it but I will say it's
very well done I kind of don't know why
more people aren't talking about it I
mean it's a legit scary film from Disney
how often too
that happened I mean we got scary
moments from other films that scare us
because we're kids and yeah some of them
go really far but this is actually
intending throughout the majority of the
film to scare you and it's actually
effective our scary movie fans just put
off that the Disney logo is in front of
it our Disney fans put off that's a
little too dark and not as obvious for
kids I don't know but it definitely
deserves a lot more attention okay I
don't think it's gonna send anyone out
running and screaming but at the same
time it just creates this mood in this
environment that just feels strange and
dark and creepy and personally I just
love it I wish more scary films aimed at
kids try this hard Alan oh if it's a
censorship issue or if people are just
too afraid to push the limit but there's
got to be more movies like this I can
tell you for certain I found a new film
to watch every Halloween the atmosphere
the environment the story the characters
the scares I'm just in love with this
film it's definitely worth checking out
with the lights off when you're all
alone and you feel like somebody's
watching you
you